be sure to stick around to the end of
the video to find out how you can enter
for a chance to win this
wacom intuos tablet courtesy of our good
friends at wacom
there are two free creative programs
that come with this wow
right you don't even have to spend three
million dollars on
adobe photoshop let's face it software
is expensive software is expensive and
you know what else is expensive
what hot dogs
all right are hot dogs expensive yeah
sure
hey i'm kevin hey i'm jackie and today
we're going to mash up characters from
the wheel
what's it gonna be jackie oh who knows
could it be
daffy duck and
[Music]
skeletor that's so odd
dora the explorer let's see who dora's
gonna be matched up with
rocco it looks like you'll be drawing
taco the explorer
i'm scared porky pig
poor pig and
jaffy duck okay porky pig and daffy duck
okay whoa that's gonna be so fun you
should go there again it's okay
i got carved garfield and
[Music]
woody wow garfield
that's kind of cute yeah okay
[Music]
that's actually so cute oh here we go
wonder woman wonder woman okay
respectable choice
and spongebob
that's gonna look great
okay all right do you believe in
yourself i do believe myself do you
believe in me
why'd you have to pause okay
i have a vision
he has no pants i remember any of this
porky has no pants
they're both not wearing pants so here's
my question do i do
spongebob cosplaying as wonder woman or
do i do
wonder woman spongy
[Music]
don't do wonder i don't want to see that
you don't want to see that so which
character are you concentrating on more
i think i'm going to give it like
rocco's
wallaby body but like dora's
[Music]
like hair and stuff you know i'll credit
garfield calvin and hopped into the far
side for teaching me how to read english
that's cute like i learned a lot of
things reading comics my
my parents bought me a lot of
educational comics even
when i was in korea like there was a
whole like comic series that that's
about like different cultures
but also the the addition of garfield
that i had came with like a little like
flip book
as part of the book so like when you
flipped you can see garfield
like moving and then another side was it
was odie that was also like another way
to like
get me excited about animation so jackie
what is your strategy here
should i make daffy duck buff or you
could do
daffy duck with a skeleton face no no
no no no now that's just a terrible idea
what makes you think skeletor is a
skeleton because he has a skeleton face
no are you not familiar with who
skeletor is he doesn't have a skeleton
phase
he literally does that's why he's called
skeletal no his name is called skeletor
because you're doing it again
you're drawing me in jackie of course
in a game of random chance with a wheel
you happen to get a simpson's chair
obviously i'm not going to draw
marge the way she actually looks i
wanted to go for the betty boop pose
skeletor's pretty cool though i like the
minimal amount of clothes he's wearing
he knows what he's about he's super buff
yeah i mean if i was this buff
i would also avoid wearing as much
clothes as possible because
who wouldn't want to see sexy
blue biceps right yeah
i mean i'd be really self-conscious that
i don't have a
i don't have skin on my face well or i
think he's compensating
i'm literally going for monstrosity
i'm actually having a lot of fun drawing
this cowboy garfield cowboy garfield
that's essentially what i'm drawing so
when was daffy duck invented
invented yeah when did thomas edison
sit down and invent daffy dub
uh i'm going to say in
the 1930s 1930s yeah i was alive then
no you weren't like i'm trying to
imagine what
the voice of fusion of daffy duck and
porky pig is like
[Music]
okay
it's like whisping also like really like
crazy
if anybody out there has the vocal
talent to fuse the voices
of daffy duck and porky pig please
please please respond what i will say
though is rocco and dora
have similar like they're both pretty
small stout characters
so similar proportions similar
proportions
well betty boop has a little more
anatomy than marge
yeah so just trying to find a happy
medium i love skeletor's
cute nails yeah he does have
uh nice little nails he has cute nails
on it
cutty type yeah it's very cute he like
takes care of his nails it's
and he paints them black he's really
compensating for that no face thing he
really
is i'm taking like porky's nose i'm
taking daffy's beak
throwing in a little bit hey june in
there me
yeah sorry you had to find out like that
is skeletor like really evil or is he
like cartoon evil is he just
misunderstood
he's definitely bumbling i will i'll
give you that he's a dum-dum
he's not the greatest villain his
schemes always backfire but it's mostly
due to his incompetent henchmen
at a certain point it's like why are you
getting the worst henchman
to do that joke you know times are tough
times are tough good health
is hard to find not a lot of uh henchmen
around these days
especially henchmen with henchmen
degrees yep the henchman degree does not
pay what it used to
yeah have you actually ever met matt
greening i've met him a couple times
how was he he's super friendly always
willing to talk
all around nice guy that must be so
surreal to just
be him all right boom
done how'd you do i think i did a good
job
yeah i think it it looks like a grim
reaper
undead buff daffy duck
this is the thing you see when you die
is he cute he's cute yeah i would swipe
right on him on tinder
so how do you think he did i think he
did pretty good it's just rocco indoors
class
how about you how do you think you did i
mean that's how i feel it's like betty
boop trying to be marge
but i mean they're the best that i could
and except that
i think this is this is pretty close to
what i have in my head
cute switcheroo you're gonna ask me how
i did on mine
no okay let's switch
oh man yours is so cute oh
dude i love this oh my gosh she's
adorable
oh i love her like garter or like
whatever it's called
this is totally rocko and a halloween
costume
[Laughter]
oh it's so cute whoa i want this monster
to be
in real life and i'm coming from its
womb
oh wow oh
why did you draw it at an up angle kevin
power
power stance it looks more like a
bdsm thing fun fact
wonder woman was actually created as a
bdsm character
the creator of wonder woman uh i want to
say his name is william
marston something he was actually like a
bdsm
cartoonist this is not a fun fact
this is more of a disturbing fact i
think you primarily use like betty
boop's body
and then flourishes of marge within the
colors
the accessories i think like the eyes
yeah like a nice mix of betty roop and
marge in the eyes i
don't think there's a part that she
didn't use all
all parts of the creatures are
represented in this drawing
plus extra there's a dash of shrek
so yours is a delight it's a delight yes
i think it's a great combination of the
two characters ah i like how you kept
skeletor's buff body but gave him a duck
face
one one suggestion i would have given
you is for his staff
you should have put a fossilized duck
head
well i i made a bird it's a bird but
like
you know what i mean like the head of
his enemies oh like
bugs bunny bugs bunny head on a steak
that's what daffy duck would that's what
daphne tour would want
yup duckatour scala duck would want
i really love what hadrian has done here
i know my garf
i know my garf hey june and like let me
tell you
you got him you got him good i think
this is actually like a really good
exercise for if you have like art block
or something right just
take two cartoon characters and mash
them together and see what you get
yeah and sometimes you can even get
something completely different and a
whole new character
out of those things i i thoroughly
enjoyed this this is what art is about
you take old ideas you make them new you
know what i will i will continue to mash
up characters because i think it's a fun
way to
stretch your character design muscles
like the muscles on your duckator
daffodil daffodil skeleton skeleton
so if you want to enter for a chance to
win this wacom intuos tablet
all you have to do is go to buzzfeed
comics instagram that's at comics on
instagram
find this post and follow the
instructions in the description
best of luck to you thank you blue apron
for the pistachio wacom tablet no
it is first of all it's not blue apron
it's sponsoring us
it is welcome thank you dollar shave
club for the welcome tablets
that is quite enough
you